بالنسبة لأوكرانيا، فهي معركة بقاء
ولكن بالنسبة لحلف شمال الأطلسي بالنسبة لبقية أوروبا بالنسبة
للعالم، فالأمر أكبر من ذلك، فهو يتعلق
بتلك القواعد التي تم
وضعها في عام 1945 من أجل خلق
عالم أكثر استقرارًا وازدهارًا وسلامًا
أه ما الرئيس  ما فعله بوتين هو
هجوم مباشر مباشر على تلك القواعد، لذلك
في نهاية المطاف
لن يكون لدى الروس قوات، وتحتل
روسيا حاليًا أوكرانيا عندما يأتي
ذلك اليوم، لا أعرف أن هناك
طرقًا عديدة للوصول إلى هناك، إحداها  بالطبع يتم ذلك
من خلال الوسائل العسكرية وأوكرانيا
تشن هجومًا في الوقت الحالي، إنه
هجوم مستمر
الآن منذ حوالي ثمانية أسابيع أو نحو ذلك،
وهو دموي للغاية وبطيء في إنتاج الكالسيوم العالي
وصعب للغاية،
لذا فإن فكرة التدخل عسكريًا  إن
طرد مائتين أو ثلاثمائة ألف
جندي روسي سيكون كما تعلمون أمرًا
صعبًا للغاية ويمثل تحديًا
لطريقة مختلفة للخروج من هذا
من خلال المفاوضات وربما
سيحدث ذلك أيضًا ولكن في نهاية اليوم
أه بغض النظر عن الطريقة  يتم ذلك من خلال
الوسائل الدبلوماسية أو الوسائل العسكرية في
نهاية اليوم أه يجب أن
تظل أوكرانيا حرة مستقلة ذات سيادة مع
أراضيها سليمة نعم لقد ذكرت
أه
الهجوم المضاد سيخلقون
هجومًا مضادًا نعم أم قلت إنه
بطيء نعم إنه كذلك  بطيء جدًا، ما
رأيك في ذلك، هل يفشل
لا لأنهم لا يحققون
تقدمًا كبيرًا نعم على
الأرض
أم
ليس بالضبط أم أنهم
حرروا بالفعل
جزءًا كبيرًا من أوكرانيا المحتلة من روسيا
منذ بداية سيطرتهم
الهجوم
أم وتحديداً على محور
الأحداث التي أه
يهاجمون عليها الآن لقد هاجموا
من خلال الحزام الدفاعي الرئيسي الأول
هذا دفاع متعمق
كان لدى الروس أشهر عديدة للتحضير فيه
حقول ألغام  إنها بها أسنان التنين، ولها
خنادق دبابات، إنها
مجموعة معقدة للغاية من
الاستعدادات الدفاعية، التي يقاتل الأوكرانيون
من خلالها، ويقاتلون
من خلالها، ويمتلك الأوكرانيون
قدرًا كبيرًا من القوة القتالية
المتبقية، وهذا لم ينته بعد
أم لذلك أعتقد أنه أه بصراحة من السابق لأوانه
القول ما إذا كان قد نجح أم فشل
فمن الواضح أنه حقق نجاحًا جزئيًا حتى الآن
أه الآن أه السرعة التي
يتم بها الهجوم أه
أبطأ مما كان يعتقده المخططون ولكن
هذا ليس بالضرورة غير شائع  في
إدارة الحرب، هذا هو الفرق
بين الحرب والحرب الورقية والحرب الحقيقية، وعندما
يموت أناس حقيقيون،
يتم تفجير الدبابات الحقيقية ومركبات قتال المشاة الحقيقية،
وتجري في
شوارع تنين حقيقية وتميل الأمور الحقيقية إلى
التباطؤ، وذلك لأن الأمور الحقيقية  الأرواح على
المحك، لذلك فكر المخططون
استعدادًا لهذا الأمر أن الأمر سيكون
أسرع قليلاً مما حدث ولكنه
لم ينته بعد وهو يحرز
تقدمًا مطردًا أه أه، كما تعلم يومًا بعد يوم يومًا بعد
يوم، ويتم قياس ذلك فيك
أعرف أربع أو خمسمائة متر في اليوم وألف
متر في اليوم،
ولكن هذا تقدم مطرد
والأوكرانيون يخوضون تلك المعركة مرة أخرى،
إنها دموية، إنها طويلة وبطيئة
وقد توقعنا ذلك منذ عدة أشهر،
هل تعتقد أن لديك  لقد تأخرت أه
في تزويد الأوكرانيين بأسلحة
متطورة
نعم هناك الكثير من التعليقات على ذلك أود أن
أقول أن هناك الكثير من الانتقادات في
الواقع نعم هناك الكثير من الانتقادات
والتعليقات عليها أم أود أن أقول إن
الأوكرانيين حصلوا على ما حصلوا عليه  لقد
احتاجوا إليها عندما احتاجوا إليها، لذلك في
بداية الحرب عندما أه في 24
فبراير وغزو الروس، كان
الروس يقومون
بعمليات هجومية بمناورة أسلحة مشتركة
والتي كانت في الأساس بالدبابات
ومركبات المشاة القتالية، فماذا
احتاجوا إليه  تلك النقطة أه، ما الذي
احتاجه الأوكرانيون، لقد احتاجوا إلى أنظمة مضادة للدبابات
أه لذا فإن العالم أه أه كما تعلم
حلف شمال الأطلسي الولايات المتحدة وآخرون
قدموا قدرًا كبيرًا من
الأنظمة المضادة للشكر مثل Javelin
at4s وتلك الأنواع من أنظمة الأسلحة
وكان ذلك  كان ضروريًا في ذلك الوقت
لهزيمة قدراتهم المضادة للدروع،
الشيء الآخر الذي كانوا بحاجة إليه هو قدرة الدفاع الجوي
من أجل هزيمة
القوات الجوية الروسية والتي في كلتا الحالتين
نجحوا في فعل ذلك لأن
القوات الجوية الروسية لم أه لعبت دورًا كبيرًا
في هذه الحرب  حتى الآن،
هُزمت المدرعات الهجومية الروسية والتشكيلات الميكانيكية
على يد مضادات الدروع، ثم قامت بتحويل
العتاد إلى الأوكرانيين الذين يقومون
بعملية هجومية، لذا ما يجب أن أفعله هو
أنهم بحاجة إلى مركبات مشاة قتالية،
يحتاجون إلى دبابات، يحتاجون إلى
تدريب، يحتاجون إلى تعلم كيفية القيام بذلك.  للقيام
بالقيادة والسيطرة على أه
التشكيلات الهجومية في مناورة المجمعات،
يحتاجون إلى تعلم كيفية اختراق
واختراق العوائق المعقدة لذلك
أعتقد أنه ربما بدأ منذ ستة أشهر أه
في برنامج تدريبي مكثف للغاية
تم إجراؤه في أجزاء مختلفة من أوروبا
لذا فقد حصلوا على نظام الأسلحة هذا للقيام
بذلك، نظامي الأسلحة، أعتقد أن
الناس يتحدثون عن أكثر
أو ثمانية صواريخ تاكومز أه و آه و طائرات إف-16
لذا فقد تم تزويدهم بالكثير من
المدفعية وهو ما تعرفه بالخبز
والزبدة  من أه المناورة الأرضية
الحرب أه هي النيران، لذا أه لديهم
الكثير من ذخائر المدفعية، ولديهم
الكثير من أنابيب المدفعية آه، لقد حصلوا على
مدفعية طويلة المدى مع أه مع
المغيرين أه والبريطانيين
قدمت أنواعًا أخرى من القدرات
التي تمتلكها الدول الأخرى أيضًا، لذا فقد
حصلوا على الكثير من المدفعية ولكن
الهجمات هي موضوع مثير للجدل
ولأسباب كثيرة
لم يحصلوا عليها بعد أه ما
زالوا على الطاولة  أه الرئيس بايدن
لم يقل لا أو نعم في هذا الوقت طائرات
إف-16 أه تمضي قدمًا في الواقع
لذا هناك برنامج تدريبي معمول به
ومن المرجح أن يتلقوا طائرات إف-16
هنا ولن يفعلوا ذلك في المستقبل